Now, let's discuss some of
the details of viruses.
First, let's take a look
at the structure of virus.
A virus infects a program by
modifying the program code.
That is, the virus code has
to be physically inserted
into the program file.
Logically, when
the infected program runs,
the virus' codes run first,
then the original program will run, so
that the user will not suspect that
the program has been infected.
And then at the end,
there could some virus code that
does clean up to avoid detection.
If you look at the infected program,
the first line controls that the virus
program will always run first.
It is critically important to put
this control in the first line
of the infected program, because this
is the only way to guarantee that
the virus code will always be run
whenever the program executes.
It is also important to put
a marker in the infected program.
Such as putting a special flag in the
second line of the infected program to
indicate whether the program has
been infected by the virus or not.
Otherwise a program can
be repeatedly infected.
When the virus code is run, it typically
first finds other programs to infect.
Of course, it will check whether
a program has been infected already
by looking at the special flag.
In addition to infecting other programs,
the virus code can also perform other
malicious activities on the system,
such as stealing valuable documents.
After performing the malicious
actions the virus will then
transfer the control to
the original program so
that the normal work can be performed in
such a way the user would not notice.
The virus code can also perform other
actions in order to avoid detection.
For example, because the virus code is
physically inserted into the original
program file the file size of the
original program obviously increases.
And this can be a tell tale sign
that a program has been infected.
Therefore, in order to avoid detection,
the virus code can compress the infected
program so that the file size
is the same as the size of
the program before it is infected.